♪♪
Wood: A JACKHAMMER USES A LOT
OF FORGED STEEL PARTS,
WHICH ARE PREFERABLE
TO CASTINGS OR PLATE STEEL
BECAUSE IN THE PROCESS
OF FORGING STEEL,
THE GRAIN FLOW OF
THE STEEL CONFORMS
TO THE SHAPE OF THE PART,
MAKING IT MUCH STRONGER.
A JACKHAMMER HAS
OVER 60 PIECES,
WHICH ARE HELD TOGETHER
BY SEVEN BOLTS.
WHY BOLTS? BECAUSE IF YOU
WELD A JACKHAMMER TOGETHER,
IT WOULD VIBRATE ITSELF APART.
THE BOLTS ALLOW
FOR VIBRATION.
COMPRESSED AIR
GOES INTO A CHAMBER,
AND A PILE DRIVER PUSHES THE BIT
INTO THE CONCRETE
TO BREAK IT UP.
AND THEN THERE'S
A VALVE THAT FLIPS.
THIS COMPRESSED AIR
THEN SENDS THE PILE DRIVER
BACK AND THE BIT BACK UP.
AND THAT JUST KEEPS
GOING IN KIND OF
WHAT'S CALLED
A SELF-RECIPROCATING MOTION.
THIS HAPPENS 25 TIMES A SECOND.
THE JACKHAMMER WORKS
OFF NEWTON'S LAW --
FORCE EQUALS MASS
TIMES ACCELERATION.
THE MASS IS THE BIT,
BUT THE ACCELERATION IS WHAT
THE AIR PRESSURE PROVIDES,
AND THAT'S A HELL
OF A LOT OF FORCE.
THE BUSINESS END OF A JACKHAMMER
IS THE FRONT-END ASSEMBLY,
AND THAT HAS A BIT.
NOW, THAT BIT POUNDING
THE CONCRETE
CAN BUST UP TO
FIVE INCHES OF CONCRETE.
Narrator: OUR TEST LABORATORY
SCIENTISTS WILL NOW DEMONSTRATE.
THERE ARE SEVERAL TYPES
OF JACKHAMMER BITS,
EACH DESIGNED
FOR A SPECIFIC JOB.
TWO OF THE MORE COMMON
BIT TYPES INCLUDE
THE POINTED BIT
FOR GENERAL BREAKING
AND A FLAT-TIPPED BIT,
WHICH ALLOWS DIRECTION CONTROL
FOR FINAL EDGE FINISH.
THESE THINGS ARE HARD TO USE
'CAUSE YOU'VE GOT TO ATTACK
FROM AN ANGLE TO PREVENT THE BIT
FROM GETTING STUCK.
BUT YOU'VE ALSO GOT
TO CONTROL IT
SO IT DOESN'T RUN AWAY FROM YOU.
IF YOU'RE GONNA
BE JACKHAMMERING,
WEAR YOUR SAFETY EQUIPMENT.
I DON'T WANT TO SEE YOU TEXTING
AND OPERATING A JACKHAMMER.
THE JACKHAMMER CAN BE
VERY DANGEROUS.
IT CAN DESTROY YOUR HEARING.
YOU CAN LOSE YOUR EYESIGHT.
YOU CAN PIERCE YOUR FOOT.
I HATE JACKHAMMERS.
WHEN THEY TELL ME TO DO IT,
MY SMILE TURNS INTO A FROWN.
I'VE ACTUALLY HAD SOME
EXPERIENCE JACKHAMMERING,
AND IT SHAKES
YOUR ENTIRE BODY.
YOU CAN'T REALLY THINK STRAIGHT
BECAUSE YOUR BRAIN'S BEING
RATTLED AROUND
INSIDE YOUR SKULL.
IT CAN CAUSE A CONDITION CALLED
HAND-ARM VIBRATION SYNDROME
FROM ALL THAT
POUNDING UP AND DOWN.
AND THAT'S A LOT OF SHOCK
FOR YOUR BODY TO ABSORB.
THAT'S WHY YOU SEE
THE JACKHAMMER OPERATOR
TAKING A BREAK.
YOU THOUGHT HE WAS
JUST SOME LAZY GUY.
YOU TRY HOLDING ON
TO THAT THING.